welcome back to new rock stars this is a
big question quarantine edition it's a
show that gives you too much information
about which superheroes will be on the
front lines when the working class rises
up to eat rich Erik Bosse here talkin
homeless Avengers with Phillip Molina
Erik as soon as we started this episode
I immediately got that sensation that I
might have a booger can you tell me if I
do it's right here right it's looking at
me you're good you great booger free
I'm curious this week about the
superheroes who are struggling right now
not just to get super villains but like
struggling with the same kind of stuff
you and I struggle with that we're all
struggling with right now money I want
to know who makes it work on a
working-class salary who is the poorest
superhero to be clear before you guys
think we're making light of this like
Eric said we are all so broke I have
literally my life I've never been this
broke I'm just laughing about it now
we're just like oh really negative money
well good luck finding it Bank the point
is that despite being so incredibly
broke we are still capable of great
amazing things as long as they don't
cost us money
so these heroes I've been thinking about
who else has really broken yet still
does amazing things as heroes so
obviously we're not talking about Batman
or Iron Man because they are
billionaires yeah those guys oh my god
you know it's just raining yeah by the
way there are so many billionaires
superheroes it's like weird then in our
world there are no billionaires
superheroes but their Black Panther
Professor X mr. fantastic Scrooge McDuck
all of them are billionaires and we
should eat them all we absolutely should
you know it kind of makes you wonder why
aren't the billionaires of our real
world doing more
the Uncle Sam the richest of them all so
we know who probably is the richest or
we have good guests that yes so who's
probably the poorest well first of all
just in trying to figure this out
you realize so many heroes you kind of
have no idea how they make any of their
money so I kind of just want to go
through some of those first so we can
get an understanding of how do they even
make money often by the way it's kind of
paired with their secret identity which
is stupid because if you can pick your
own secret identity pick billionaire
playboy and then you are just set but
most of them instead pick poor person
like me or even if not billionaire
playboy you could be like Clark Kent
right he's his secret identity is
gainfully employed he's basically like a
New York Times writers and a columnist
so that would put him making between I
look this up between 150 and 300
thousand dollars a year depending on his
robe that's how much New York Times
writers are making yeah you almost did
that job and then you pussied out that
would be why I got such a big kill fee
for an article they never ran exactly I
was a baby if you're a columnist you
make so much money but so okay let's
talk about the people who are less
obvious we don't really know their jobs
okay so I'm just gonna pair some of
these together so let's talk about cap
and Bucky how are they doing
well here's the thing that's very fun
that turned up in my research about this
cap was in the army right right was
assumed dead turns out he was not dead
he never died so and this is now
confirmed by the US Army like the real
US Army technically if this happened he
is owed 66 years of back pay from the
Army oh they actually way this the army
they wouldn't get too specific but they
did agree officially they would owe him
more than three million dollars okay
yeah so he gets VA benefits nothing to
needs health care me just like give it
to anyone else but also this is from the
comics active-duty Avengers in the 80s
we're getting paid twenty five hundred
dollars a week if you had just had for
inflation now they that's like two
hundred and eighty six thousand dollars
a year if you're on the current roster
of the Avengers and he was for about
four years until civil war so that's
another million bucks he has right there
which makes sense I mean there's a lot
of hazard pay that's baked into that
that's that's a fair amount to pay
Avengers right now Bucky on the other
hand very similar situation and yet he
wasn't an Avenger so he didn't have that
he also was technically an enemy of the
state
so he doesn't have that back group in
the army but here's what he does have
that they both qualify for Social
Security checks choo choo choo choo
usually the free money you get for
surviving America he both can get that
they're both eligible and I mean like
let's be honest if he gets like in dire
straits
sell that metal arm baby oh yeah take
that to any pawn shop how much you
looking to get out of this these things
are very very common I'll give you 40
bucks for it
I can guarantee you they don't go board
up your hands I'll take that off your
shoulder actually so then speaking of
people who are our former enemies Black
Widow
obviously a at one point was not exactly
on our side her and Hawkeye though have
both been on the shield payroll for
years and grace since shield isn't quite
governmental we can assume that they
actually are probably making closer to
the private contractor rates that you
would differ like being a mercenary an
elite soldier so we're talking at least
150 to 250 thousand dollars a year which
is pretty good but you gotta imagine I
bet they're spending a lot of that on
work expenses like you know recharges on
the widows bite and new arrows like that
that's right
these exploding arrows especially also
shield like went down too so I figure
like worst case scenario Hawkeye has
that amazing beautiful farmland that he
apparently does no farming on so they
could easily start like a summer camp
together he could teach archery she
could teach murder and ballet it'd be
beautiful
yeah or they can just buy a bunch of
like tigers and big cats and set up some
cages and turn it into a zoo oh my god
I'm never gonna financially recover from
this they can buy a zoo tiger cats
murder ballet We Bought a Zoo take a
kids movie ballet hey buddy balloon what
was it
meat bag people any better linen
speaking of making their own businesses
- I just want to throw this out there
really quick Wonder Woman we're not
sticking just marble here across almost
every version of the comics so not even
just like some weird obscure one Wonder
Woman has an agent and not only does her
agent book her appearances with like
major fees her agent in
a lot of versions of the comics has
worked out a licensing deal for her so
she has all kinds of Wonder Woman toys
and merged she makes a she's good
basically she's like a Kardashian don't
laugh like that oh wow I mean that's
probably the most realistic in an
economic sense depiction of like a
superhero in comics they would all have
agents none of them would be good with
contracts they'd all be economically
exploited so if they're famous they
should have someone representing them
daredevil probably good with contracts
because he's a lawyer but oh do they
make them in Braille that's they do they
do they have to print it all in Braille
what's a Braille printer like I'm be
speaking of making your own money just
basically say you don't have to worry
about dr. strange or Scarlet Witch
Scarlet Witch can manipulate odds so she
goes to Vegas or the horse track and
she's good oh wow yeah she can actually
cancel out dominoes like good odds by
the way yeah I was gonna say that's like
dominoes power but yeah it was crazy
yeah dr. strange in my research he
actually has run into money problems cuz
he thought he was still rich but he's
not he wasted on a surgeon money but he
literally this really happened he used
to just sell stuff from the sanctum
sanctorum like precious JD just like
sell it just to make money so Juan got
really mad at him so he was like fine
I'll do it the other way and he just
made a huge pile of cash and then his
money problems were solved you should
have started that way I guess the rules
of like Harry Potter where poor wizards
are still poor they can't just like
conjure gold that should apply to doctor
some [ __ ] there needs to be like a
Bernie Sanders in the Harry Potter world
it's like why can't Wizards make their
own money my Bernie Sanders sounds like
a ghost you must repent I endorse you
but always I could haunt your dreams Joe
to be fair Joe Biden has been dead for
six years so here's the meat of it who's
not doing great we're talking like you
and me level of poor oh yeah first of
all there's kind of an obvious one if
you think about it just spider-man right
spider-man AMC you currently just a
student and then he's under the care of
an aunt who's in ER nurse who of course
Oh should be paid so much money but
realistically it not oh yeah now more
than ever yeah but here's what's
interesting
like well no he goes on to have work in
the comedy stuff so sure he becomes a
photojournalist that we know that he
becomes and he takes all those pictures
of spider-man except so if you watched
the Tobey Maguire spider-man movies he
negotiates he gets $300 for four
pictures of spider-man now we're a lot
of work to get he had to like defeat
villains to get these pictures yeah but
then in spider-man 3 Eddie Brock Topher
Grace negotiate sit down because he
willing to do it cheaper to just $50 per
picture so he's almost getting nothing
already and then that was back then
turns out in my research about
photojournalism it's a dying career they
actually pay less for pictures right now
than they ever have before because of
the internet oh yeah everyone's got a
phone everyone can quickly upload
pictures from the event from all kinds
of angles onto Twitter they don't really
need to pay for a journalist to go get
in harm's way to try to get a picture
anymore yeah that makes sense
oh that's a bummer yeah he's still in
the comics he becomes a teacher he does
a bunch of other stuff but like pretty
consistently stuff that does not pay
very well and isn't the whole like
Spider Man webbing that was initially a
money-making opportunity that he tried
to sell it but he couldn't keep it from
dissolving it's like he should have done
the 3m glue that turned into post-its
because it wasn't strong enough but that
was already taken again I even if you
just think about money making he could
go back to wrestling but the problem is
now everybody knows that he's spider-man
so they'd be like this guy he's cheating
tested for steroids yeah
testing for radioactive spider up next
oh this one hurts we got to talk about
my boy Luke Cage oh poor poor guy he
somehow scrounged up enough money to put
together his own bar and then kilgrave
made him blow it up and then you'd be
like oh well you know he maybe he'll get
an insurance payout from that here's the
thing
one for some reason he couldn't put the
bar under his own name so he used a fake
identity to create the bar which already
so yeah it's all fake and it's all under
the table but on top of that try going
to your insurance company and say yes I
was the one that blew up my bar but I
would like money please
I mean those insurance companies even if
it was an accident they don't have to
pay
so you know you remember from when you
burn down your apartment right yeah they
those investigators they see through
everything will you left a note for
yourself right I did well how am I gonna
remember to burn my apartment down I
have a goldfish brain my eggs burned
down apartment sell eggs for money he
also after that whole Jessica Jones
storyline he worked in a barber shop not
as a barber but as that like the
sweeping boy just picks up the loose
hair where I go the barbers do their own
sweeping oh really
that is not common oh we don't go to
these fancy barber shops so they have a
boy just to sweep another boy just to
open the door it sounds like you go to a
barber shop where none of the barbers
cut your hair they let the sweet boy
practice on you
he also almost gets evicted no matter
what's going on he can't even pay his
rent but you shouldn't be hopeless
because he saves his landlord from some
thugs she forgives some of his rent
basically he gets the idea of her Heroes
for Hire and he monetizes his power so
he's on the upward trajectory he's an
opportunist this guy heard about
bootstraps yanked rips through feet into
the space so just move on to poor poor
Ant Man the guy I don't know if you
remember he was working at Baskin
Robbins earning minimum wage we know he
wasn't doing great already then Plus
think about that job and paying child
support not doing great
somehow he scrounges up enough money to
open his own security business kilgrave
makes him blow it up no but that'd be
very funny too it just made everyone
blow everything up that they were no
still it gets messed up cuz Louise
manages it into the ground
fancy raspberry filling represents our
company's red and we're days away from
going on business Oh days away
damn jumped Oh he looked this up
basically all of that he's just not
doing great in general so ant-man
leaving a sad life but at least he looks
perma 33 and at least somehow he affords
an a house in San Francisco even like
CEOs can't afford houses in San
Francisco he went to Kentucky he saw a
cheap house shrunk it put a hunting
airplane brought it over to San
Francisco found a plot of land blew it
up exploded killgrave killed killed
whatever people were sleeping on that
plot of land
exactly dead quickly I'll mention just
hopping back over to DC for a sec there
actually are some rich Robins like Tim
Drake is independently wealthy but Dick
Grayson is so poor he obviously you know
he was already like a carnie
and then Batman takes him in here like
well Bruce Wayne no Bruce Wayne gives
them a tiny allowance and it's such a
small amount that the poor kid wants to
get Batman a birthday present but he
doesn't have enough money with his
allowance yeah how much money do you
have like 69 cents you know what that
means for chicken McGee
so you have to get a job as a golf
caddie to become over the present to
just give it back to Batman what a
brainwashed kid oh this poor kid hey I
don't feel any pity for him though
because like it's basically saying the
kids of billionaires right it's like
daddy doesn't give me enough of an
allowance but he still lets me use the
property in the grounds the mansion it's
like little [ __ ] you're still rich
you're still gonna inherit a [ __ ] ton of
money Shanna baby I don't know they
don't get along so well the only reason
I don't feel bad for him is cuz Dick
Grayson [ __ ] that dude oh so much do you
think Batman holds his inheritance over
him like we bring home that girl again
you might get ridden them to the will I
don't know why he's British master Bruce
says if you told to bring home a white
girlfriend I would explain my mind only
what there's because I feel like 80% of
the situation's where kids are written
out of wills it's always racist based
this is you digging your hole oh no my
tears these chairs ah there we go
hello yeah weird that were in the same
kind of chair but it completely
different sides of the continent mm-hmm
Antarctica it makes us feel closer than
ever so finally this is my guess for who
is the poorest poor sap hero of them all
who doesn't happen to be like a swamp
creature so sorry it's one thing oh it's
because I mean that dudes nothing but of
the actual people we know you sure it'll
have a
I don't see one in there I just feel it
at the entrance the poorest of them all
this might surprise you Bruce Banner so
I know super respected scientists we
associate him with all this amazing
stuff but even if he was a well
respected scientist unless he has a ton
of really amazing patents under his belt
he actually didn't get paid that much
and then if you think about it he hasn't
even done that job in like over a decade
it's been so long since she's been a
working scientist he's been on the run
trying not to you know Hulk out and then
he literally went to space for like a
really long time and if you're even
referencing the Hulk from the old TV
show that one that Bruce Banner is
famously a drifter oh he's homeless yeah
yeah very sweet guy here's also probably
the biggest issue of all and why he's
just perma poor Bruce Banner is
technically liable for any of the
charges associated with Hulk's
destructive path this means I looked
into it there's no insurance for this he
is millions and millions of dollars in
debt to various cities to Harlem I mean
it's like you know he has just debt
collectors calling him but he can't take
the call because then I'll make him
angry and then he'll smash something
then he'll be more in debt which is
exactly my own life that I'm currently
living by the way yeah so unfortunately
because of his Hulk's ID there's no way
that guy's ever gonna be out of debt I
declare we're sure in the MCU the the
most poverty we've seen by a superhero
has been by Bruce Banner he was one
who's homeless sleeping on the streets
of Mexico and Guatemala and then even in
the Avengers when we catch up with a
Ruffalo Bruce Banner he's basically
doing gigs as a doctor going to place to
place in Calcutta and then a little girl
rips him off he's like I should've
gotten paid first yeah the poor guy
long story short answer your question
Eric Tony Stark was probably the one
that paid for this forum
well thank you Philip that was a very
enlightening thing to think about all
these people through these same context
that we view our lives in because our
lives are a matter of dollars and cents
right we're not looking at like times we
save the world peace yeah and let's
acknowledge again it's these heroes are
making no money but they're still heroes
and that's obviously the case with
currently what we're learning about our
teachers and our first responders and
our health care workers nobody makes
enough money to do the terrible things
they do like take care of children yeah
you know in general right now life is
there's a lot going on there's a lot of
things to stress you out whether it's
like how am I gonna afford my rent or
like am I still gonna have my job in six
months just in general there's a lot of
things stressing us out I feel like one
good thing we could do is just like hit
the pause button and chill and relax
after our weekly Friday meetings like we
started doing this thing where we just
like keep the meeting going yeah we
talked about this last week and it's
been honestly like the best part of my
week is just like connected with each
other and we crack open some beers which
thanks to our friends at Coors Light
we've been able to do yeah I also like
that it signifies now is the weekend
which was very hard to track before yep
now as you know the mountains on your
can of Coors Light and bottles turn to
blue when it's chilled to perfection
it's really guys like the perfect beer
for just chillin as it's cold it's crisp
for you guys that were worried about
those six pounds I came the other week
I've been drinking Coors and I still
have re lost three of those pounds which
is not too hard to do cuz only 105
calories and that's why Coors Light is
the one we choose when we need a moment
of chill when you need to reset reach
for the beer that's made of chill
reminder you can of Coors Light
delivered to you by going to get that
Coors Light calm and they have a bunch
of local delivery options for you
celebrate responsibly Coors Brewing
Company in Golden Colorado
okay on to some bite-sized questions
that I'm gonna answer hit me with those
cues we have some of my favorite
bite-sized questions this week by the
way I'm jealous that you're answering
these okay this one comes from Ryan
Thomas at time for Yeats uh
theoretically can Hulk throw a bowling
ball at the moon hit it and if so what
kind of damage he gonna do to the moon
if the moon was made of spare ribs would
you throw a bowling ball at it it
started as Bill Cosby and then I
remember that wasn't Kazi that was Harry
Caray
Harry Caray I shared this one on Twitter
and it was like one of my favorite
threads I got a lot of research and
science help from Robert and Scott and
Ray and Chris you guys were great many
others okay so here's what we were able
to figure out Earth's escape velocity is
eleven point one eight six kilometers
per second or kilometers per second so
just to explain escape velocity it's a
velocity at which the sum of an object's
kinetic energy and gravitational
potential energy is zero it allows you
to escape the Earth's orbit and you can
break Earth's gravity and drift off into
space towards things like the moon the
problem is if Hulk for whatever reason
he would want to throw a bowling ball at
the moon say mad at 710 split or yeah
the bowling ball is just the thing
within his grasp unlike a lunar rocket a
bowling ball doesn't have like an
ongoing force emitted from a rocket
booster that allows it to continue
propelling and propelling it we need all
of its force to break that orbit in
Hulk's initial throw also you run into
the problem that the bowling ball is
made of a material that would probably
melt when it was going through the
atmosphere due to the heat in the
friction but it would depend on whether
that bowling balls core is either made
out of iron oxide as many of them are or
ceramic because some holy balls
apparently have ceramic cores if its
ceramic it could survive that heat
because it has a higher melting point
which is why your toilet bowl survives
your heat that's right I sit on it for
hours and the friction I love us whoa so
there was an article written for Wired
by Rhett Elaine and he did the math on
how hard
Superman would have to uppercut
someone's head to send them into space
so it's kind of comparable because the
human head weighs 8 pounds we learned
that from Jerry Maguire
and in in many bowling balls at least a
light bowling ball is 8 pounds most of
them are heavier than that but let's use
that as an example his math because he
did lots of math using the air
resistance using heat using trajectory
all that stuff four point two trillion
Newtons in order to overcome Earth's
gravity to hit escape velocity at the
point we need to break Earth's orbit ok
ho if Hulk throws the ball with that
force accounting for air resistance even
atmospheric he theoretically the bowling
ball could escape Earth's orbit but Hulk
would also have to calculate trajectory
because he's aiming for the moon he's
not Church trying to get out to space so
based off of where he is on the earth he
would have to basically curve the ball
at that exact angle in order to strike
the moon because it's a small target I
used to have a video game where monkeys
threw bananas at buildings and you had
to put in the angle and the floors the
same thing Phillip now just answer the
other part of the question what would it
do to the moon at that point just by
escaping Earth's gravity the baldness
wouldn't necessarily be moving that like
a super strong speed or momentum so it
would probably just hit the moon make
like a meteorite style crater in it
unless we're talking in the comics like
world breaker mode Hulk where he can
smash planets but that's like a comics
version of the hawk that's completely
ignoring physics since not even worth
everything so the moon survives all that
yeah at that point when you when you
send like a lunar rocket to the moon
it doesn't smash the moon and that has
way bigger mass are you already told us
smash the moon have you seen the footage
of when they landed on the moon and if
they did have reverse thrusters but like
yeah they they that's when they were
trying to land men on the moon but they
definitely shot stuff at the moon and
and it doesn't blow up the moon we're
lucky the moon hasn't tried to hit us
back by the way you know the movements
were aided from like probably a comet or
something hitting Earth and then spit it
out into a little moon anyway next
question big
brow I feel you bro on Twitter at
captain brow you really underlined this
how big how big whoohoo Steve Rogers B
if he started out with the height and
body structure of Dwayne the rock
Johnson before he gets the Super Soldier
Serum how big would he get so there's a
couple ways it's through this amazing
question so in a capped America the
Winter Soldier he goes to the Captain
America Museum and they actually give us
some numbers they show that skinny Steve
played by Leander Dini the body double
in the first movie was 5/3 and weighed
95 pounds before the serum the
transformation into buff Steve led to
him being six feet tall in 240 pounds
after the serum that would mean a 14%
increase in height and a 153 increase in
weight which makes sense to taller you
get you get a lot heavier for every and
shoes yeah yeah you grow out you grow
out more than you grow up right
lucky so let's look at the wrox numbers
The Rock's numbers are reported as he's
65 any weights 260 pounds so with those
same size increases if you were to just
apply the same numerical increases that
skinny Steve got the rock would be 7 3
and 658 that's a lot of s so just to
give you some context that's two inches
taller than Shaq but double Shaq's
weight
in theory Steve Rogers incredible growth
was actually the result of him already
being weak and skinny to begin with and
that weakness made him more appreciative
of strength it made a more heroic and
more brave because he had to go into a
lot of fights knowing he would lose and
it's those qualities that amplified the
serum according to dr. Erskine so
theoretically if Steve began with the
body of the rock he probably wouldn't
have lost as many fights he probably
would be a bit prouder more aggressive
more vain about his body so he wouldn't
had those inner qualities that caused
the growth to be so expansive we know it
was the same kind of serum that Blonsky
took to become abomination in the hoch
movies and he didn't get bigger he just
got more aggressive and then he took
this too
version of banners blood to become
abomination so like you know just not to
talk too much put up the Dwayne Johnson
because he's a great guy he cares about
his fans and Dwayne I've always liked
you so Eric is the one that yeah he's a
great guy I want to hang out with them
but he also refuses to lose a fight in
any of his movies Eric how did you
manage to angle this question into
sharing your beef with the rock you use
the rock is an example he seems like an
alright guy and the saying like
bodybuilders who've spent their entire
lives crafting their bodies to look that
way to get huge don't want to think
about like losing fights and they're
coming back from other things where they
grew up like Lucy fights are getting
beat down they need some kind of
motivation so I don't think they're
thinking about like how much more can I
improve on this you don't think the rock
grew up getting his ass kicked have you
seen the 90s picture of the rock he's a
big guy but he's from Miami he's
probably getting in some fights you're
from Miami you know how violent that
place can be
I've died every time I've got my hippie
all right listen fun all right we have
time for one mailbag question what have
we got this week Phillip what's
something that exists on the Internet of
you that you wish you could erase but
you cannot why are we supposed to share
this well there's Phillip and I both
have a lot of stuff that were ashamed of
and we're not gonna direct you to it if
you find it we're not gonna acknowledge
that it's ours but there's there's some
things that yeah I think we can give him
a couple clues no well first of all real
quick I have been deep faked in
everything you've ever seen oh hi mark
I've been deep baked by you Phillip in
several things what are you talking
about there's been a lot of x-rated
things that I can't erase cuz they're
online now I try to find that picture
recently because it's easy I don't have
you remember I used to show up whenever
you across and Google it was one of
those pictures but recently it suddenly
stopped showing up there oh good thank
God there if there is an Internet god I
have a story to this it's not gross so
when Phillip and I first moved to LA we
moved out here to do comedy and to do
live comedy and comedy writing one of
our favorite shows
is 30 rock the reason we liked it is
everyone on that cast and the writing
staff did improv which is what Philip
and I spent all of our college years
doing so like Tina Fey and Jack McBrayer
and Judah Friedlander it's got ads it
they all looked at the second city and I
oh yeah and then the writing staff had
Donald Glover who did stuff at UCB
Aubrey Plaza played a page on that show
and that she was an NBC page and that's
how like she was able to get that job
and so I kind of idolized the character
Kenneth the page because Jack McBrayer
I'd seen old videos of him doing improv
so I was like when I first got out here
I'm like oh I'll be a CBS page and that
was my first job I wore a red blazer I
gave the tours I managed live studio
audience is I remember you you asked me
to take a picture to send to your
parents oh yeah we have that job I was
so proud and I was like this is gonna be
my start well
one month into the job I was pranked I
was pranked into a period on an episode
of a travel documentary series that I
did not give my consent but because I
worked on the lot it was already in my
start paperwork don't know I guess story
camera for something I don't know you
might know this okay well this travel
show was hosted by a young guy who's
actually a moderately well-known
influencer in comedian and I'm not gonna
tell you its name or what the name of
the show was because I don't want you to
find it I don't want to make it seem
like I'm talking because he's actually
cover your mouth when he can say it so I
know it is okay huh he's like yeah yeah
yeah now that you mentioned that it was
very memorable actually I think about it
so this is a guy he's like a comedian he
won a contest for a new cable network
that was launching and he got this
travel show so this dude showed up
unannounced when I had me busiest shift
I was coordinating the live audience for
a very popular game show and in my job
and that shift rotation I was looking I
who had to tell people to go home and I
to turn them away
and they would yell at me but like I if
you can tell what show was good enough
yeah very popular
Delanie hosting so I was yeah I was
overwhelmed I had to like write I'd had
people process their paperwork I to keep
people calm for three hours as they were
waiting to get into the studio this
[ __ ] shows up
the whole morning pestering me because
his producers are like that's the guy
you're gonna bother that's gonna be our
kin at the page and you're gonna like
rattle him and they thought it would be
so funny to have this stiff like nerd in
his red jacket get rattled by their
comedian host and like be pranked and
like they didn't talk to me about this
but like they didn't know I was like
also a comedian also an improviser and
like whenever I tried to do funny bits -
like yes and him and respond
everyone shut down the guy would stop
playing along and the producers would
make me stop and redo it and I'm like
I'm trying to do my job right now but
like they didn't give a [ __ ] and I
remember one of the bits was so the idea
was the host of this show is like
bribing me to let him sneak backstage to
the show to get on the show and and he
had like a five dollar bill that they
gave him that he's gonna try to stuff in
my pocket so when he handed me that I
played along and my like my response is
like you're just gonna give me five
bucks like give me a 20 they don't pay
me enough here I'm starving to death
just give me I'll do anything for $20
and as I was like doing that character
bit they they shut it down they're like
no no no no because they wanted me to
like be confused and befuddled and like
awkward and get a raw reaction because
they thought that would be more
authentic and funny I'm like just bring
me in on the bit so we could go home my
sister actually saw this on TV I don't
think anyone would see it Wow and she
called me making fun of me she's like
why Rhys is such a nerd in this and so
you can find this final version it
exists somewhere on YouTube but like I
look super lame my name is spelled wrong
and the kind they use the worst take and
I actually just I had to stand there and
straight man the comedian and pretend
like I was uncomfortable and awkward but
like I went backstage and came back and
said I pulled some strings they're gonna
let you backstage after all your big
night yes and this is like my first TV
appearance and I was like this sucks
like I took this job thinking it would
be like my first launch pad into Fame
and I just felt like I was exploited and
no one had me sign a release form or
anything there's just like oh yeah this
loser like I hate the prank shows we're
like the butt of the joke is someone who
has like the worst job it's people
trying to do their job like
is fine cuz you're pranking a celebrity
that's fun to watch celebrities freak
out but like me I'm just like a kid I
have no respect for anyone that would
ever prank you in any way whatsoever
delicate flower
and yeah should be appreciated in a
museum from an S I belong in a museum
careful light I don't I haven't break to
them except the look I gave that guy yes
we cut cuz that's all I'll find them
dude there's so much you and I both know
like we have a lot of the same stuff
and again our only fans 5 5 bucks a year
all of it what we're gonna do it free
we're like porn oh yes ya know the one
thing that comes to mind right now at
least but I could probably have a
hundred answers to this question is when
I was starting out in YouTube it was so
important to like collab like you got to
appear on other people's stuff that's
the only way you'll grow and I so I had
no collabs with anybody I was making my
own channel with these stupid little
sketches and I I had an opportunity with
someone who had a channel that had a ton
of subscribers they're like you can come
up here on a show of mine and it was a
trivia show and I was like oh I'm pretty
good at trivia I'm excited about that
and then I get a text like maybe a month
before that's like hey you're still
gonna do the trivia thing I'm like yeah
and they're like how hairy are you what
was the first time oh no
no and I was like not too hairy and
they're like okay say you're really
hairy though and I was like okay I'm
really hairy and then so there was an
email that came through with like a
producer on it and they're like and it's
like here's the date we're gonna shoot
all this stuff and they're like how are
you and I was the old man so hairy and
they're like perfect so I said I was
really hairy but I'm not and so then
it's like it's coming closer to that
date and then I thought I started trying
to research what they talking about
and I find they have a trivial in this
channel but it's one where you're
shirtless and they are waxing you if you
get anything wrong they wax your hair
off um and I guess they were gonna like
spring that on me at last moment and so
at this time I'm like I'm gonna be like
kind of naked on this channel so I start
to like make sure I'm in the best shape
I can be which at the time I thought was
like a skinny as possible like a little
in beanpole I was thinking out with you
too much at that time it was just so
skinny so I like crash dieted and I
tried so fast to get as skinny as I
could because I know I was gonna pee
like shirtless on this thing and so I
finally get to like the lowest weight
I've ever been thinking that that's
gonna be attractive or something and I
I'm getting ready to do the thing and
then they have to push it uh uh a while
and so I kind of like start gaining
weight again and then they they suddenly
are like actually we are gonna be able
to do it sooner
so then sometime like they knew I'm like
damn I gained I gained so much weight so
I have I have like 48 hours until the
shoe so I stupidly this is like one of
the dumbest things I've ever done I
decide I'm not gonna eat a single thing
for 48 hours oh that's not gonna help
and I'm not gonna drink any water so I
get that really like oh then then look
yeah all right yeah so the day the
morning comes and I go and I'm like okay
since it's morning before I can I can
now have something small to eat and
something small to drink because it's
the morning
of the shoe and so I'm walking to like
Starbucks on the street and I literally
fainted oh my god
completely fainted from not eating or
drinking to the most stupid idiot and
then and it's like this should have been
I should I should have been like 18 when
this happened I was not 18 um and so I
come to to some guy going like you okay
man you okay it was like I'm great never
don't worry about me and I remember I
was bleeding from my eye and I still go
to the shoot but I'm worried that I'll
pass out again so I have a load of pasta
like I just stopped a morning like I
need all your pasta you're like Michael
Scott eating fettuccine yeah to
carb-load exactly so I end up at the
shoot it is what I thought it was it's a
stupid waxine show and I have this huge
pot belly from all the pasta I ate but
I'm also like I've got this severe
headache from being dehydrated and
malnourished and I can't think of any of
the answers to anything so they're
waxing me on every [ __ ] question the
little hair that I have and I remember
when I took off my shirt and stuff
though I heard the producer off-screen
go he said he was Harry not they had to
find hair on me to wax after like two
questions or like well that's everything
he's got I was like wait try this spot I
hate it it wasn't funny I don't I kind
of blacked out most of the experience
but it's on YouTube it's a show I still
remember the top comment was that things
people do to be YouTube famous well
folks you can find that or you go find
our shame go out find our shame shame at
the pier blocks fine my I'm so excited
as soon as we're done taping I'm gonna
go fine that's clip I don't think you're
gonna find it
but maybe we'll say oh well folks that
is our show now a reminder you can join
our official discord right becoming a
patron at patreon.com slash new rock
stars and you can submit questions to us
that way we usually see those before we
see anything else we'll try to send us
you can also get an audio version of the
show by subscribing to new rock stars
big question wherever you get your
podcasts and yeah thanks to everyone who
submitted questions a really good
question this week this is why a lot of
Matt and you can send us your big
questions on Twitter of course using the
hashtag big question or mail us at our p
o-- box listed here you follow me i da
vas follow philip at philip molina
and follow new rock stars on all socials
and subscribe here on YouTube to get too
much information about the stuff you
care about see you next week stay safe
stay healthy see ya
[Music]